on quitte la politique pour un tout
autre sujet jérô Andre bonjour bonjour
avec vous on va parler du virus du du
sida mais notamment des populations
dites invisibl vous avez organisé une
conférence de presse ce matin pour
justement mettre en avant ces fameuses
populations et je vais d'abord commencer
par un par un chiffre 6100 voilà il
s'affiche c'est le nombre de découvertes
de séropositivité en France en en 2011
alors le on peut dire que le nombre de
découvertes reste stable depuis 2008 par
contre il avait quand même diminué entre
2004 et
2007 ça veut dire que il y a une
recrudesence ça veut dire queil y a un
relâchement ça veut dire qu'il y a des
ces populations dites invisibles dont on
va parler alors ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il y a un relâchement au niveau
effectivement de la communauté
homosexuelle cela dit il est clair que
le chiffre reste relativement stable et
justement avec le professeur Alain Sabel
ce matin l'enjeu c'était de se dire
pourquoi ce risque ce ce ce ce chiffre
reste stable malgré que les risques de
devrait être en diminution puisque en
théorie les gens devraient avoir
conscience que le virus du sida fait
encore des morts et et donc il est pas
de Bonon d'être contaminé aujourd'hui
alors c'est peut-être la cause de ces
populations dites invisibles mais ça
veut rien dire population invisible si
ça veut dire beaucoup de choses parce
que effectivement comme vous le savez à
chef prention on est quand même des
spécialistes des populations invisibles
c'est-à-dire des gens qui ont une
sexualité qu'ils cachent qu'il
n'assument pas forcément alors on a les
fameux HSH les hommes ayant des
relations sexuelles avec d'autres hommes
don effectivement on est spécialiste et
où on intervient peut-être pour
expliquer clairement sont des hommes qui
ont une vie hétérosexuelle qui pour des
raisons de ce sont des bon père de
famille ah ça je sais pas s'ils sont
bons pèr de famille mais en tout cas
c'est des hommes qu'on vit voilà c'est
des hommes qu'on vit hétérosexuel et
pour des raisons de de de fantasme ou de
d'homosexualité cachée ou que sais-je on
des relations ponctuelles avec des
hommes ils ont et fait ils sont
hétérosexuels père de famille marié
femme enfant le Renau scénique le siège
auto à l'arrière mais effectivement ils
viennent
il ils viennent avoir donc des rapports
sexuels avec d'autres hommes quand on
les interroge ils nous disent qu'ils
sont hétérosexuels qu'ils ont
effectivement des aventures avec
d'autres hommes mais ils ne se sentent
pas homosexuel pour eux ça n'a rien à
voir avec donc de l'homosexualité et
clairement ils viennent sur ces lieux
pour consommer entre guillemets
homosexuel mais il ne ils ne l'assument
pas c'est une et du coup à ces hommeslà
quand on leur parle quand on leur parle
de sida ils veulent rien entendre ils
veent rien entendre pas les concner ils
doivent estimer que ça pas conc ben
voilà parce qu'effectivement il y a pas
de prévention générale euh donc
dépopulation en général maintenant on
fait la la prévention euh vraiment
ciblée et là la vraie problématique
c'est qu'ils ne se sentent ni gay donc
ils ne se sentent pas dans la prévention
à destination des homosexuels ils se
sentent pas non plus dans la prévention
hétérosexuelle puisque du coup ils ont
des rapports sexuel enfin des rapports
homosexuels à certains moment ils n'ont
accès à rien au final et du coup ils
vivent cela dans la clandestinité c'est
bien pour ça que on trouve beaucoup de
personnes c'est opositive sur ces lieux
de rencontre extérieure qui je le
rappelle ont besoin quand même d'exister
alors avant de poursuivre cet entretien
je voudrais juste rappeler un chiffre un
chiffre deux chiffres d'ailleurs en 2011
150000 personnes environ vivait avec le
virus et 30000 tout même ignorent cette
infection porteur de cette infection
donc c'est quand même très important oui
et l'idée c'est vraiment de trouver ces
30000 personnes à des endroits qui sont
clairement enfin qu'il faut cibler nous
on est un peu des snipers dans la lutte
contre le sida c'estàdire qu'on va
chercher les gens là où on pense qu'ils
sont s positifs c'est pour ça aussi on a
vu d'ailleurs quelques images au début
d'entretien où il y avait dans ce lieu
de rencontre dite sexuel qui se trouve
pas très loin d'ici à 50 ans pas très 50
ans mais il y en a un sur 50 ans en
Eveline aussi alors on nintervient pas
avec le camping-car et on conseille
effectivement aux gens d'aller plutôt
sur le lieu qu'on voit donc à l'écran de
manière à ce que nous on puisse donc
faire de la prévention beaucoup plus de
manière beaucoup plus importante que si
on allait au cœur de Saint-Quentin dans
des bosquets dans des four et cetera là
où on sait qu'il y a de la consmation et
c'est difficile de les aborder ces
populations dites invisiblebl quand vous
arrivez comme ça avec le camion de hchef
prévention vous arrivez sur des lieux de
de drague est-ce que c'est c'est
compliqué ou petit à petit le dialogue
s'instore alors nous on fait ça depuis 8
ans quand même en île-de-fance ouest
donc effectivement on est connu reconnu
pour ça ce qui ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est jamais facile de le faire mais on
a développé une méthodologie dans la
méthodologie d'aller vert c'est-à-dire
que il y a des associations qui se
contentent d'être derrière un stand
c'est très bien des gens bien qui font
ça nous on est plutôt dans la notion de
dire le camping-car c'est un point
stratégique de ralliment cependant on a
nos animateurs de prévention qui vont
avec les sac avec les sacs à dos
directement au contact du public dans
une notion d'aller vert donc on va au
contact des populations les plus à
risque alors là on vous voit justement
c'était ce matin au contact des
populations vous étiez devant le le
parvis de la la mairie du 4e
arrondissement à Paris donc justement
pour oui avec Monsieur le Maire
Christophe Girard qui nous a fait le
plaisir d'ailleurs de de de nous prêter
donc euh la salle des mariages
d'ailleurs de de la Mairie de Paris
enfin de de la mairie du 4è l'idée
c'était effectivement de dire voilà le
marais il y a beaucoup de prévention qui
est faite et nous effectivement en
grande banlieu on souffre du fait que
euh les pouvoirs publics souvent euh que
ce soit la RS les ministères ou autres
ont tendance à croire que tous les Gay
sont dans le milieu gay c'est faux euh
tous les gazs ne sont pas dans le Marais
euh effectivement quand on fait de la
prévention dans le Marais il faut
imaginer que il y a tout un tas d'autres
gens qui sont gay et qui n'ont accès à
rien en terme de de de prévention et et
c'est vraiment ça l'idée c'est d'aller
là où les autres ne sont pas tout comme
nous on est peut-être l'une des rares
associations à dire depuis des années
mais le ministère commence à l'entendre
que tous les migrants ne sont pas en
foyer migrant 5 % des migrants sont en
foyer migrants donc il est grand temps
de faire de la prévention et du
dépistage aussi au cœur des cités avec
effectivement des unités mobiles alors
l'occasion de cette conférence de presse
il y avait le professeur Alain Sobel
vous en avez par parler il soigne depuis
1985 des personnes qui souffrent du VIH
et il évoque justement cette épidémie
cachée on écoute le professeur Sobel ce
sont effectivement les gens dont je
viens de parler qui ne sont pas qui ne
se savent pas copositif qui n'ont pas
accédé au dépistage pour quelque raison
que ce soit des raisons personnelles des
raisons où par exemple où il n'assument
pas leur la la prise de risque qui est
le cas quand quelqu'un se vie
hétérosexuelle prend des risques avec
des relations homosexuelles clandestines
euh il ne va pas accéder au dépistage
parce que il n'a pas du tout
l'impression de prendre des risques
et parmi ces personnes il y a des
copositifs que l'on pourrait traiter et
ainsi les rendre beaucoup moins
dangereux pour les autres personnes avec
lesquelles ils ont des pratiques
sexuelles là encore souvent très
clandestine donc la clandestinité est un
obstacle considérable aux soins de
maladies
transmissibles c'est beaucoup plus
simple de fonctionner avec des personnes
qui assument leur sexualité quel qu'elle
soit que qu'avec des personnes qui se
cachent on le voit bien dans les pays
totalitaires où il y a une
stigmatisation de l'homosexualité par
exemple ou même une stigmatisation de
toute la sexualité le il est très
difficile dans ces pays-là de lutter
contre des maladies transmissible parce
que par définition on n'existe pas voilà
donc on comprend bien que ce sont des
populations qui sont difficiles à
appréhender aller vers elle on a vu
aussi les le camion he de prévention de
de chef prévention qui circule dans dans
ces lieux vous des tests minutes est-ce
que ces tests minutes qui sont du coup
complètement anonymes sont la solution
alors juste avant je rappelle quand même
on appelle ça nous des tests minutes
d'ailleurs on a un slogan qui s'appelle
une minute pour savoir mais on a des
bonnes langues en ce moment sur 50 ans
en evelg qui ont tendance à dénigrer nos
actions donc je le rappelle c'est une
minute le test donc se fait en une
minute mais effectivement on a des gens
qui pensent que on fait aussi des
entretiens en une minutes je rappelle au
pouvoirs public que non non achef
prévention ne fait enfin fait bien son
travail oui oui non mais non mais bien
entendu mais en ce moment on est en
train de souffrir d'un dénigrement qui
est assez colossal et et et
effectivement donc on rappelle aussi
qu'on a donc les entretiens qui sont
faits qui sont bien faits et d'ailleurs
beaucoup de gens de Saint-Quentin ont pu
en bénéficier ne serait-ce que récemment
à Espace Saint-Quentin h et à
l'université également ai alors je
reviens sur ces tests minutes parce que
du coup est-ce que c'est la solution
pour ces population dit invisible parce
que c'est pas facile pour un père de
famille euh d'aller dans un centre dans
un laboratoire d'analyse
ou aller voir son médecin traitant
disant j'aimerais bien me faire dépister
du SIDA on se doute que c'est quand même
pas simple d'en parler à son époue c'est
encore pour eux c'est en fait super
simple c'est-à-dire qu'ils n'iront pas
ils ne le feront pas tout simplement
parce que déjà ils ont du mal à ramener
les préservatifs qu'on leur donnent chez
eux souvent les préservatifs finissent
dans la route secours de la voiture là
les tests s'il n'était pas minutes si
c'était pas des tests avec résultats
immédiats il ne viendrait pas se faire
dépister pour la bonne et simple raison
que que ben il n'y aurait pas de
possibilité pour eux de dire tiens je
reviens dans une semaine à tel endroit
ils n'en savent rien ils viennent
clandestinement sur ces lieux de
rencontre donc on est obligé d'avoir une
réponse ultra immédiate et et l'analyse
que vous faites est bonne effectivement
c'est des gens qui n'irait pas au
dépistage et là ça veut dire depuis
combien de temps vous mettez en place
ces test minutes alors là ça fait un an
un an et le résultat il est bilan vousz
ben il est à 2,34 de personnes de
découverte de séropositivité sur le 78
et le 95 donc les deux mélangés en
sachant qu'un centre de dépistage
anonymé gratuit est à 0,2 % alors voilà
aide fait du dépistage dans le milieu
gai c'est 1 % et donc nous 2,34 en
sachant quand même une chose c'est
qu'effectivement on va nous cibler
vraiment les populations r donc oui
effectivement un centre de dépistage ne
fait que 0,2 mais parce qu'ils prennent
du tout venant nous on est vraiment des
snipers de la lutte contre oui parce
vous allez au devant de de ces
populations ditarisque est-ce que vous
avez justement l'impression qu'il y a
sentiment d'une augmentation de la prise
de risque oui parce que finalement on se
dit bon le sida même si j'ai le virus je
vais prendre des comprimés hein ça se
soigne que ça comme on soigne une une
grippe et ben c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose quand même non une grippe à
la limite c'est plus sympa je crois oua
c'est plus sympa vous avez d'ailleurs
souvent reçu des gens qui étaient
effectivement céropositifs clairement on
a une difficulté c'est qu'aujourd'hui
officiellement nous ne mourons plus du
sida et on peut prolonger sa durée de
vie sa durabilité grâce à des
trithérapies qui fonctionnent d'ailleurs
plutôt bien parce que aujourd'hui on a
d'ailleurs des comprimés qui sont
combinés où en une gellule on a la
trithérapie complète une gellule une
prise et donc effectivement on a des
laboratoire qui pour pas l'impression
que le virus s banalisé et le virus est
banalisé on a des jeunes qui ont de
moins en moins d'information sur les IST
VIH on on se rend bien compte que c'est
une maladie qui ne fait plus peur et
pourtant on on a quand même 6 à 7000 cas
de nouvelles contaminations tous les ans
beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de jeunes
homosexuels ça se vérifie aussi par le
fait de la stigmatisation qui est faite
plus les populations sont montrées du
doigt plus les populations sont à risque
mais moi j'aime bien rappeler aussi que
40 % des cas de cont de nouvelle
contamination sont homosexuels mais 60 %
60% des cas sont hétérosexuels il serait
grand temps qu'on fasse quelque chose
pour nos hétérosexels
alors justement sur cette augmentation
de prise de risque on va à nouveau
écouter le professeur alin Sobel qui
évidemment va dans votre sens on
l'écoute je pense qu'il y a plus de
prise de risque qu'à une certaine
période si vous voulez le le sida
maladie était une hantise dans les
années je dirais 90 à 95 l'apparition
des traitements semble avoir banaliser
cette C cette maladie heureusement
d'ailleurs c'est c'est formidable comme
comme comme résultat mais la
banalisation c'est aussi accompagnée
d'une moins grande vigilance dans dans
les prises de de risque et de plus de
comportement transgressif qu'il n'y
avait avant allez je voudrais citer
encore un autre chiffre décidément on va
dire que j'aime beaucoup les chiffres
mais bon celui-là est quand même un peu
terrifiant je trouve la France se situe
au 2e rang des pays européens pour le
nombre de nouveaux cas par an oui 2 rang
des pays européensanchement on aima bien
se glorifier d'autre chose que de ce
deuxè rang c'est juste une catastrophe
on le dit pas on a l'impression que la
prévention qui est faite au niveau du
VIH est une bonne prévention nous on
continue à dire qu'on tap pas au bon
endroit oui effectivement des gay il y
en a partout quand on va à l'université
de vers Saint-Quentin et qu'on découvre
des jeunes gay qui ne peuvent pas
assumer leur homosexualité et qui en
plus de ça sont en prise de risque parce
qu'ils n'ont pas accès à la prévention
ou quand on a des publics en situation
de prostitution on se on se demande
pourquoi la France ne réagit pas plus
que ça pour nos jeunes hein aussi et une
dernière chose on a parlé des des
camions d'achet prévention on a parlé
des tests minutes je voudrais aussi de
un petit mot sur les autres outils de de
prévention à venir sur Internet
smartphone oui alors nous on a déjà
démarré effectivement euh les
smartphones l'idée c'est effectivement
quand on est sur une zone où nous sommes
présent on géolocalise grâce à des
applications euh donc euh smartphone euh
on géolocalise donc les gens et on leur
propose de venir faire un test de venir
boire un café de venir discuter tout
simplement au camping-car ça marche
plutôt bien donc on aimerait aussi que
les pouvoirs publics se penchent un peu
sur la question parce que il y a des
vraies nécessités puis les jeunes sont
aussi beaucoup sur smartphone donc c'est
mais financièrement votre association ça
va ou et ben écoutez j'ai envie de vous
dire avec 20 % au moins minimum au
niveau de l'agence régionale de santé
non ça ne va plus c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on médiatise beaucoup nos actions
parce qu'on se rend compte qu'il y a un
désengagement donc de l'État je rappelle
quand même que nos actions sont censé
être des actions prioritaires puisqu'on
fait partie du plan national de lutte
contre le VIH donc qui va jusqu'en 2014
les associations de lutte contre le sida
craignent qu'il n'y ait plus de plan de
lutte contre le sida et c'est bien parti
pour en tous les cas nous on aura une
mobilisation très clairement vis-à-vis
de ça et non effectivement ce n'est pas
un problème de baisse de financement
suite à la crise c'est vraiment
visiblement une volonté de considérer
les associations comme étant des
prestataires de services je me sens pas
prestataire de service de qui que ce
soit et nous en tout cas on considère
qu'on fait un boulot qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas assumé par les pouvoirs public
donc oui effectivement on trouve que ce
n'est pas normal voilà c'était l'appel
lancé par Jérôme André à l'encontre des
pouvoirs publics merci beaucoup d'être
venu sur le plate du 78